sind die extreme wetterverhältnisse in
der letzten zeit tatsächlich auf den
klimawandel zurückzuführen erwischte uns
also schon jetzt mit voller breitseite
die auswirkungen sehen jedenfalls
katastrophal
ihr habt es mitbekommen die kanalnetze
sind die überhaupt ausgelegt für die
folgen des klimawandels ist nämlich
wirklich skurril wie wird das in zukunft
weitergehen und können wir uns irgendwie
wartet man das alles jetzt zwar geht es
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja ihr habt alles mitbekommen die
letzten jahre waren hinsichtlich der
weltweiten temperaturen rekordverdächtig
nicht nur 2014 2015 und 2016 sondern vor
allem auch 2017 war außergewöhnlich laut
weltwetterorganisation wmo habe die
temperatur 1,1 grad über dem
vorindustriellen wert gelegen mit dabei
außerdem temperaturen von mehr als 50
grad celsius in asien rekord hurricanes
in der karibik und dem atlantik sowie
eine sehr lange dürre in afrika aber wir
brauchen gar nicht so weit weg zu gucken
auch hier bei uns in deutschland folgt
ein unwetter dem nächsten über viersen
in nrw liegt ein tornado hinweg in
wuppertal sind keller und die ganze
innenstadt überschwemmt und in der nähe
von bochum werden zwei frauen vom blitz
getroffen im saarland werden ganze
straßenzüge verwüstet gullydeckel
schießen nach oben unterführung sind
vollgelaufen und die innenstädte saufen
ab essen aachen oder sauce und die liste
die kann man ewig weiter fortsetzen und
das hätte was ganz kurios gezeigt die
kanäle in den städten sind nicht für den
klimawandel gerüstet es gibt einen
sanierungsstau und das obwohl bundesweit
rund vier milliarden euro in die
kanalnetze fließen teilweise sind die
rohre länger als 50 jahre boden und bis
zu 100 jahre alt das muss also dringend
geändert werden aber ist diese
unwetterlage noch normal
die antwort ist ganz klar nein normal
ist das nicht klarkommen unwetter
solcher größenordnung schon mal vor aber
eben nicht so oft und gehäuft wie in der
letzten zeit und letztlich ist es keine
überraschung wenn man sich mal anschaut
dass die atmosphäre immer wärmer wird
der kreislauf sieht so aus umso wärmer
die luft ist desto mehr feuchtigkeit
kann sie aufnehmen
doch diese entlädt sich dann in form von
gewittern samt agl sturzfluten sturm und
wolkenbrüchen zu erwarten eigentlich
eher im hochsommer
doch dieses jahr sind wir deutlich
früher dran dazu passt die rekord wärme
im mai in diesem jahr der
deutschlandweit mindestens zwei grad
wärmer war als man nach dem vierjährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre seit
81 bis 2010 hätte erwarten können in
manchen regionen im norden war es sogar
viereinhalb grad
zu warm für das potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung pik ist die lage
ganz eindeutig mit einer temperatur
zunahme von dem jahresmittel einem grad
celsius befindet sich deutschland mitten
im klimawandel als ereignisse können
statistisch gesehen zwar keinen trend
bestätigen aber was wir derzeit an
unwetter und lang anhaltender hitze
beobachten bestätigt die annahme der
klimaforscher zu den folgen der globalen
erwärmung so der wissenschafter fred hat
man vom pk seiner ansicht nach wird sich
der derzeitige trend weiter fortsetzen
im norden und osten wird es immer
trockener und im süden und westen von
deutschland werde die gewitter lager
weiter akut seien dazu hat man dieser
trend wird sich fortsetzen wenn der
ausstoß von treibhausgasen unvermindert
anhält
tatsächlich hatten sich klima
forschungsteams lange schwergetan solche
extremen wetterphänomene in einem
direkten zusammenhang mit dem
klimawandel zu bringen doch mittlerweile
machen schnelle computer und optimierte
klimamodelle das möglich in einer großen
studie haben 33 forschungsgruppen aus
der ganzen welt wetterphänomene im jahr
2014 analysiert die entscheidende frage
waren die extremwetter ereignisse von
2014 auf natürliche schwankungen
klimasystem zurückzuführen oder waren
sie tatsächlich folgen des
menschengemachten klimawandels thomas
kahl einer der beteiligten forscher mit
dem fazit wir können demonstrieren dass
einzelne ereignisse wie temperatur
extreme oft mit den von uns zusätzlich
in die atmosphäre gepumpten
treibhausgasen verknüpft sind andere
extreme darunter regenfälle sind weniger
eindeutig auf den klimawandel und
menschliche einflüsse zurückzuführen der
klimawandel hat also durchaus einfluss
auf die häufigkeit und spannbreite von
solchen extremereignissen im jahr 2014
beispielsweise machte man ihn
verantwortlich für die hitzerekorde in
europa china argentinien und korea
und auch für die lange dürre in
ostafrika die starken regenfälle im
winter 2013/2014 in großbritannien und
die winterstürme seien dagegen nicht
klar auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen
und in zukunft wird das wetter
jedenfalls immer nur noch extremer
werden dazu heiko paeth von der
universität würzburg wenn man in der
bodennahen atmosphäre mehr in
die hat weil die
treibhausgaskonzentrationen gestiegen
sind und einen höheren wärme gehalt in
den unteren atmosphärenschichten
bedingen dann sollte man alleine vom
standpunkt der physikalischen
plausibilität davon ausgehen dass es in
zukunft mehr extremereignisse lebt wir
müssen also dringend anfangen uns zu
wappnen
kommen wir noch mal auf die probleme der
kanalisation soll größere kanäle zu
verlegen das wäre unwirtschaftlich der
aufwand wäre gigantisch im besten fall
müsste man verhindern dass die
regenmassen überhaupt erst in die
kanalisation gelangen
dafür müsste das wasser in den boden
versickern doch die flächen sind zu
stark versiegelt es wäre beispielsweise
einen anfang flächen wieder zu
entsiegeln also statt einen parkplatz zu
asphaltieren mit glitzersteinen
pflastern die dann wasser durchlassen
doch tatsächlich wird in deutschland
jeden tag mehr als ein quadratkilometer
zubetoniert doch das eigentlich große
problem ist dass es trotz der ganzen um
wetter ereignisse der letzten zeit bei
vielen leuten nicht mehr als
schulterzucken auslöst denn abgesehen
von den stürmen und
starkregenereignissen haben solche
unwetter auch langfristige schäden die
dann auch nicht mehr nur regional fatale
folgen haben werden es drohen
ernteausfälle durch trockenheit und
fischsterben in warmen gewässern was
brauchen wir noch mehr an mahnungen
ereignissen dass wir endlich alle
reagieren und was tun
schließlich sind wir die erste
generation die die folgen des
klimawandels nicht nur abschätzen kann
sondern auch hautnah miterlebt
vielleicht sind wir auch die letzte
generation die die katastrophalen folgen
für die gesamte menschheit noch abwenden
kann
ich überlege und wenn ich etwas
gemeinsam machen wollen habt ihr ideen
schreibt sie unten in die kommentare
wenn ihr keine videos zum thema
klimawandel zu anderen allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die
kaputte aber auch sehr auf youtube im
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social nvidia
abonnieren das geht hier gibt es das
neueste aus der social media welt dafür
hier drauf kriegen aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und die geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt bis dann bleibt da